it's pretty cool to be able to be part
of something so big we are making the
next generation of human spaceflight
possible every day
I'm Amanda Curtin Jensen and we're in
New Orleans at Michoud assembly facility
and we're developing the technology to
put a man on Mars
[Music]
Bowen was a part of the holidays we were
part of shuttle and now it's Space
Launch System SLS is the world's biggest
most powerful human rated rocket ever be
built our current mission is to take
astronauts deeper into space than ever
before at this SLS vehicle is the
platform that we will do that with I'm
Chad Bryant I'm the NASA core stage
manager for SLS the core stage is the
central piece of the rocket it contains
an oxygen and hydrogen that mixes
together to form a very explosive
combustion two million pounds of thrust
that gets it off the pad it deeper into
space than ever before
going to Mars it's not easy and so it
requires a lot of detail in the design
of the rocket it's all got to work
together perfectly in order to execute
the mission we have human life's at
stake all it takes is one part to fill
and we can lose the mission you can't do
anything of this scale without
tremendous amount of teamwork like it's
basically like this whole dance and
we're the dance conductor you're excited
to come to work every day because you're
part of developing the technology to put
a man on Mars which would be an ultimate
new frontier
[Music]